gli altri ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono al vostro pilota e
oggi giochiamo a flight simulator allo
ragazzi non so assolutamente miei
ma niente completamente nulla non ho mai
neanche aperto sto gioco prevedesse da
zero riesco a volare a caso
completamente senza fare niente senza io
voglio provare a vedere se da zero
riesco a far decollare nero che poi
questo simulatore vero cioè senso questo
è fattore in modo realistico comunque
prova a volare da milano malpensa
ok a londra londra gatwick rovesciamento
arrivai lì trova bene quindi abbastanza
easy tra i voli che ho fatto la mia vita
questo è uno dei più easy che ho fatto
mille volte e ci sarà chi jet nove
ragazzi bellissimo dai cacchio dai dai
dai dai sta volando parlando quando si è
staccato si è staccato ha funzionato
solo il volo oddio cosa devo fare
mantieni la manetta al 70 per cento
durante la salita iniziale aumentava
netta per i neri per la potenza di luci
manetta mar se mi dici il tasto kat
non lo so madonna quanto fatto bene
dall'aver ragazzi non ci posso credere
come tolgo il carrello il carrello non
al collo della spesa coda ma oggi all di
voce san siro ma cos'è no ragazzi sto
male ma perché prende google maps
praticamente sto facendo volare un
boeing sente contro due cappato il
genere quando vai in macchina metteva
vai verso via torino perché no invece
quale dove cazzo e londra
ma la mia domanda è ma il mondo è
veramente quel quelle lago di como
regali non è lavori come caccia è
barbara è il mondo di
c'è veramente tutto il mondo perché la
domanda è lecita perché sanno utilizzato
google maps google earth per fare sopra
c'è veramente tu c'è anche che vado a
casa mi ha praticamente ci posso andare
a casa mia o sbaglio non lo so ora c'è
veramente assurda sta roba sei veramente
così calcinate del pesce non è proprio
dove volevo andare ma chissà se posso
atterrare all'aeroporto di calcinate del
pesce sono quasi 10.000 piedi ai ragazzi
quindi buono all'altitudine abbiano così
raggiunta perché sono le cose bravo
potrei essere un pilota fa vedere da
dentro me si vede c'è più calma là
dentro il mio co pilota e si è suicidato
prima di salire con me ha fatto solo
bene bene la radio dove radio maria so
che quello la polmoni torino serve per
capire se siamo inclinati se siamo
dritti che cacchio siamo però per adesso
dove la vedo l'altitudine da qua ci sarà
scritto da qualche parte latitudine
minchia dove cacchio eccola la 10.000
mente o che allora basta 10.000 basta
adesso puoi scendere
scendi scendi alla mostra mappa l'abi la
v
io schiaccia un po il gioco un polo
logistico of thee oh sees a capo tanti
servirà mappa grossa però c'è proprio il
giorno ecco ecco la ok ho sbagliato
direzione a sinistra virare eccolo non
me ne frega niente di chi ci sta dentro
l'aereo vogliamo dove dico io pia forte
ok guga ragazzi londra milano dura circa
due ore quindi non è che possa d'ora
registrare caso c'è sempre cucinato ero
in modo
con rischio ma tranquilli a posto di
questo controllo è tutto sotto controllo
ragazzi tranquilli basterà su fibra cosa
c'è e che ha portato qualcosa dentro si
è aperto uno sportello cosa c'è qual è
il problema
lo so perché si inclina in alto su aereo
poi con il problema l'intendo di aaron
audio
oddio dio dio e vorrei andare a vedere
casa mia se effettivamente c'è vero
perché lontani non ci voglio arrivare
fino a londra che palle che non posso
possa atterrare da un'altra parte sono
scherzavi che a non farvi 23 google e il
proprio che vibra tutto sto cazzi aereo
comunque se volessi atterrare come
faccio io ho bisogno di un atterraggio
di emergenza da etico svolto strada
perfetto
oddio sto facendo una di quelle cose
manovra e un po strane che non dovrei
mai fare ma fa niente
ma chi la velocità pari a 250 no di
quanto voglia dire che ne so io che si
intuisce c'è un modo per diminuire lo
aspetta fermi fermi guache che chi
schianto come siccome si riduce la
velocità guarda dentro l'abitacolo e
ragazzi asca rimini milano c da c
no non so come si diminuisce la velocità
ragazzi so che devo tirare con la leva
li ragazzi ci sono dei problemi tecnici
o stesse rassicurate personale il pillow
tutto a posto lo faccio sempre ogni
domenica mattina si può atterrare
sull'acqua ragazzi credo che
l'atterraggio sull'acqua si possa fare
un rischio film aspetta che atterra
aspetta aspetta che atterra ragazzi il
gioco incredibile perché il mondo è
quello vero c'è tutto il mondo e quello
al fatto hanno fatto google maps
il pie pazzesca sta roba a terra sul
lago che credo che sia quello di como
non è quello di como non lo so che
questo lago no non è il lago maggiore
che era la fabula sarò di gardaland dove
gardaland voglio andarci credo che ci
sia allora se questa e lago di garda
garda non dovrebbe essere laggiù ma non
penso sia lavori gara come si atterra
perfetto se non meno facente vado a
parlare di una che finisca al lago però
vabbè ci provo lo cita in aree accessiva
ho capito come cazzo sir allen non me lo
dici io non ho idea di come si rallenti
non ne ho idea se riconoscete casa
vostra vi dispiace non son capaci di
addio aspetta madonna lady disastro
sfiorato allora aspetta che succede ma
non è vero non ho toccato niente ai
stressato sia eccessivamente
l'aeromobile va bene allora ghazi
l'ultimo volo e per milano ovviamente la
destinazione malpensa in realtà io
voglio sorvolare milano però questa e
malpensa scusate a destinazione e linate
the korea adesso sulla basile colorano
problemi neanche sull'atterraggio
la tradizione sempre però almeno polare
normale è fattibile ho capito un sacco
di roba e là ma adesso ho capito quando
si dice andare a manetta dramma retta
non significa andare veloce significa
che è la manetta tutta alzata e non va
mai messa tutta
sono già la cia pinner kiersztan ottima
cosa ho imparato oggi ragazzi inizio
ragazzi a intravedere la metropoli che
questa qua se si vedono le torri ragazze
sole cose che dovrebbero saltare i più
all'occhio un da milano è questa al 6
mila per cento citylife dovrebbe essere
qua ha forse questa si tira il super il
duomo non lo so che non sarà capito qual
è quella milano il 3 mila per cento naga
l'abbia trovata perfetto mi faccia
impazzire che riesco ad andare
esattamente dovevo non è così difficile
guidare un aereo dopo due tra volta che
ti si è schiantato spero che queste cose
non le dicano anche i piloti veri allora
allora diminuisci pure la velocità tanto
ce ne sbatte le palle siamo a milano
loro non ci sono tutte le torri ci sono
quella della alliance perché le sono
ancora in costruzione sono andate su
anche le altre due è porco demonio non è
questa di life è questa qua
ma è questa porco il demonio queste san
siro o dio dio parco sempione e no
questo ne san siro allora questo addio
questo è il parco sempione bellissimo
che se la è il caso di parco sempione
stavo scherzando
questa cavo lenti ma tu non è bellissimo
raga e milano ecco il duomo lo vedo e
questo overspeed un cast ci sono
voglio atterrare sul nuovo madonna
ragazzi oddio oddio oddio oddio
oddio che gioco pazze o e realistico al
massimo sono emozionatissimo uno zio
chissà come decollare veramente da los
angeles sarà bellissimo voglio fare
l'altro episodi sta roba perché è
impagabile ragazzi impagabile basta
basta per oggi basta
signori questa è la flight simulator dio
mio
cioè non so cosa dire è la cosa
veramente fatto meglio del mondo cioè
veramente fatta e non è un gioco
pazzesco quindi direi che posso
concludere qui il video di oggi è il mio
computer pezzo sia morto perché mamma
mia sta recando robe assurde però non mi
si sia chiuso il processore nel mentre
vi ringrazio per ha visto questo video
chat e mi piace fatemi sapere se ci sono
costi che vorreste che io ho visitati
nel possibilità di fans in grade e
magari ci andiamo da soli gli piace
iscritti al canale e noi come sempre ci
vediamo e l'oppressione della ragazza
[Musica]